also in Tokyo one of Japan's top tourist
destinations is no more
the legendary ski chief fish market the
largest in the world has closed for good
headed for a new and controversial
location lucy craft visited the area and
has this report
it's an image that has come to define
japan and its famous cuisine rows of
premium grade tuna auctioned off before
sunrise expertly carved up by
wholesalers in a matter of hours the
prime filet will land on sushi trays and
dinner tables across this fish loving
nation for 83 years kiichi fish market
has been the gold standard for seafood
handling about fourteen million dollars
worth of fish daily making it by volume
one of the biggest fish markets on earth
a ramshackle charm and jam-packed aisles
of suki cheese in her market made it
irresistible to tourists drawing an
estimated 2 million annually dodging an
army of speeding turret trucks was part
of the experience those little carts are
crazy it's almost like out of a Star
Wars movie they're flying around you
have to watch out and make sure you
don't get run over
the trucks will still Rumble but at a
spacious modern and some say antiseptic
new market a few miles away the city
says the move to modern quarters was
long overdue a gas plant once occupied
this location while over 500 million
dollars was spent on decontamination
many of sketchies longtime vendors fear
the new site will taint their brand
Yoshinobu Yoshi Hoshi a third-generation
wholesaler fought in vain to have the
old market renovated north the wall on
oil some of us have broken down in tears
over all the effort our forefathers have
poured into the old fish market he said
I haven't cried or that it hurts me no
less if the city has its way the former
of historic market had become a glitzy
commercial too
for CBS this morning Saturday Lucy craft
Tokyo so reminds me of what happened
here in New York City with the
Meatpacking District Lee huh location
location location when it comes to real
estate it right next to a nice river or
the sea yes depending on how you see it
sad for a lot of those people have been
there along